depuis on va dire le 20 février
bon je travaille montrez-le un petit peu
level un tout petit peu qu'on voit là à
l'antenne que ça fait quand même une
belle liasse voilà et donc en fait alors
il y a quoi sur ces notes chaque jour
mais chaque jour qu'est-ce qui s'est
tout ce qui s'est passé donc sur le
terrain et dans le diplomatie aussi
diplomatie donc effectivement ce matin
je commence par Anthony blinkena en Cara
et puis on a le nombre d'enfants qui qui
ont été tués 461 enfants malheureusement
tués depuis le début de la guerre et
puis l'arrivée de Joe Biden et puis au
fur et à mesure et donc chaque page
correspond les 461 enfants vous mettez
la source oui alors tout est possible
tout est sourcé et donc en fait je peux
refaire
un livre en préparation peut-être un
livre on verra mais ça me sert
essentiellement effectivement bah à
pouvoir suivre au quotidien répondre aux
sollicitations médiatique savoir
exactement où l'on est où l'on en est et
ça permettra peut-être à jour de refaire
l'histoire de la guerre d'accord alors
puisque vous avez sur la foi de cette
somme de documentation en quelques mots
pour vous l'état des forces militaires
de part et d'autre comment vous le
décrire en fait il y a eu il y a eu
plusieurs phases bien sûr
cet automne c'était une phase qui était
plutôt
où la dynamique était du côté ukrainien
il reprenne personne le 11 novembre les
Russes sont plutôt sur une sur un
retrait et puis avec l'hiver on le front
va se figer en particulier dans le dos
basse autour de la ville de barthout et
on le voit depuis plusieurs semaines
tous les efforts se concentrent autour
de cette ville alors cette ville c'était
70 000 habitants avant guerre c'est une
ville qui n'a en fait aucun intérêt
stratégique c'est pas une vieille clé
c'est pas un carrefour
c'est devenu un symbole alors on a d'un
côté les forces ukrainiennes qui est
actuellement sont plutôt sur la
défensive
il y a un phénomène d'usure au bout d'un
an et de l'autre côté vous avez des
forces russes qui pratiquent la tactique
du rouleau compresseur c'est à dire que
à défaut d'avoir réussi et bien on
envoie des vagues de combattants
notamment la fameuse milice Wagner et on
utilise l'artillerie c'est la doctrine
je vais dire
la plus classique et donc on a cette
ligne de front les Russes grignonnent
petit à petit mais on voit que aucun des
deux adversaires n'est capable de
prendre le dossier sur l'autre elles
avaient vous êtes surprise par la le
fait que la l'armée russe a semble avoir
réussi à se régénérer un petit peu pas
vraiment surprise au sens où
[Musique]
tu es annoncé en Russie qui vient être
complété en plus par les appeler
réguliers donc on attend encore 120000
hommes qui seront injectés prochainement
dans le système militaire et puis
aujourd'hui le président belaus a
annoncé dans le cadre d'un Conseil de
sécurité exceptionnelle qu'il allait
former des bataillons Bélarus qui
compteront jusqu'à 120 000 hommes qui
viendront encore supplément pardon prêt
tes mains fortes aux troupes russes en
Ukraine ce qui veut dire qu'en fait il y
a une supériorité en termes de
ressources humaines indubitable du côté
russe qu'il convient de prendre en
compte pour pouvoir si nous souhaitons
toujours fournir un soutien à l'Ukraine
puisque du côté de l'Ukraine étant donné
que la mobilisation est déjà générale il
n'y a quasiment pas de marge de manœuvre
donc l'équation militaire est assez
simple de ce point de vue là et donc
c'est pour ça que les Ukrainiens nous
demandent instamment de passer un niveau
supérieur au niveau de l'armement et
Véronique guillermat le secrétaire
général de l'OTAN a dit cette semaine
que il y avait en fait la qualité du
côté qualité des armements du côté
occidental et là que la Russie parvenait
à compenser par la quantité à la fois
probablement la quantité d'hommes mais
aussi de d'obus etc c'est c'est une
bonne description oui ce qu'il a dit
aussi c'est que nos capacités de
production étaient inférieure à
l'utilisation massive de tous ces
armements particuliers les obus les
munitions il y a 5000 obus je crois
qu'ils sont tirés par jour du côté de
trémien et 20 000 du côté russe et en
fait on n'arrive pas à suivre les
cadences de production en Occident
n'arrive pas à suivre la production
d'armement Nicolas l'état des forces
aujourd'hui vous diriez que elle
s'équilibre ou que il est urgent de que
les chars promis aux Ukrainiens arrivent
pour rééquilibrer un peu il est urgence
pour compenser effectivement la
faiblesse numérique il faut de la roman
qui soit plus précis plus performant
est-ce que l'Occident peut fournir aux
Ukrainiens tout le problème c'est la
lenteur de ce d'acheter de nom et sans
doute que ces chats arriveront un peu
trop tard par rapport à la fin de
l'opportunités
on aura 14 blindé légers français qui
vont avec la semaine prochaine 14 c'est
pas grand-chose et sur les 20300 qui ont
été promis aux Ukrainiens français il y
a peut-être 120
non parce que ça va au fur et à mesure
et on estime que les 50 premiers seront
là au printemps en mars avril donc
combien le temps qui est très long et
c'est vrai que les Ukrainiens avaient
une fenêtre de tir sur si on peut dire à
la fin de l'année dernière pour prendre
l'avantage voilà ça passe à la Russie
qui n'est pas encore amené se mobiliser
sur le front c'est-à-dire qu'elle se
referme parce que
malheureusement peut-être on ne sait pas
mais en tout cas vous en pensez qu'il y
a un moment je suis assez d'accord je
pense que
la quantité du côté russe donc
effectivement c'est une course de
vitesse dans dans les mois à venir c'est
à dire que si on n'arrive pas à fournir
suffisamment de matériel aux Ukrainiens
aussi le mois d'avril la balance risque
quand même de peser en faveur des forces
russes d'autant plus que et là aussi on
doit se rappeler des lois de la guerre
des fondamentaux la démographie fait
partie des lois de la guerre il y a un
pays qui a 140 millions d'habitants
l'autre il y en a 35 alors bien sûr
divisé par deux les hommes les femmes
ainsi de suite mais et Vladimir Poutine
il connaît son histoire russe même s'il
l'a réécrite par coeur en 1812 la Grande
Armée de Napoléon il y avait la
profondeur stratégique il s'est passé la
même chose en 1941 1943 et de toute
façon
il est pas question d'envahir la rue
sinon non bien entendu mais lui
considère qu'il a il a le temps
stratégique devant lui et qu'il a une de
toute façon une ressource une main
d'oeuvre ouais tant pis pour les pertes
ça fait partie de la culture russe Elsa
Vidal cette ressource d'abord
les Russes il faut qu'ils adhèrent quand
même à la guerre alors certes ils sont
plongés dans une un bain de propagande
mais quand même les échos que vous avez
les sensations les retours que vous avez
c'est que la majorité de l'opinion
soutient cette guerre alors la majorité
de l'opinion se prononce bien sûr pour
soutenir l'effort patriotes qui leur est
demandé dans la perspective généralement
de croire que la Russie est attaquée
ensuite derrière ces déclarations
publiques de soutien se cache des
stratégies très différentes et en
général les stratégies d'évitement au
niveau personnel au niveau familial qui
consiste à trouver des solutions pour
faire échapper les hommes de la famille
qui sont concernés au service militaire
ça c'est dans le cas où soit on a une
conviction très affirmée contre la
guerre ou soit on est dans une situation
économique et sociale qui vous permet
d'envisager l'armée et la guerre comme
autre chose qu'un ascenseur social ou
une possibilité d'évolution pour le
moment la plupart des hommes qui ont été
envoyés combattre en Ukraine sont
malheureusement
issus de région si défavorisées que la
perspective de la main est périphérique
oui c'est-à-dire soit des régions du
études du Caucase russe soit des régions
sibériennes en fait des régions qui sont
en majorité peuplée de population non
slaves ils sont assez bas malgré tout
dans l'échelle sociale de la société
russe et cette mort possible s'inscrit
malgré tout dans un risque qui est
acceptable parce que elle peut aussi
amener des ressources tout à fait
considérables à des familles qui sont
dans des zones vraiment très pauvres
dont on a du mal à se représenter le
dénuement
les 500 à 1 million d'hommes qui ont fui
en septembre ce ne sont pas des
opposants politiques c'est pas des gens
qui ont fui par opposition c'est plutôt
des stratégies individuelles d'évitement
comme vous le dites donc il y a une
acceptation on subit d'autant plus que
Vladimir Poutine veille à ne pas taper
sur dire la jeunesse éduquée de
Saint-Pétersbourg et de Moscou alors
c'est pas Vladimir Poutine je pense ce
sont les gouverneurs locaux ou les mers
locaux qui ont eux ont mis un point
il y a un tri manifeste de de la
mobilités à protéger certains groupes de
population c'est que oui et il faut être
un acteur politique de poids alors que
dans d'autres dans d'autres régions on a
pu au contraire faire en sorte que la
mobilisation se passe même au-delà du
cadre légal prévu ce que je veux
rappeler très brièvement parce que
c'était un élément qui passe souvent en
dessous du radar européen c'est la une
forme d'opposition au projet de guerre
en Russie qui existe et qui se manifeste
au sein de l'appareil du corps
institutionnel en fait de ce qui est
l'administration contre le pouvoir
politique c'est à dire que les la
manière dont la mobilisation a été mise
en oeuvre en Russie s'est fait de
manière tout à fait illégale
c'est-à-dire dans un cadre absolument
excessif qui n'a respecté aucun des
bornages administratifs qui avaient été
prévu aucune des règles ce qui fait que
le parquet lui-même a contesté certaines
organisation et a réussi à envoyer chez
eux renvoyer chez eux 9000 hommes alors
9000 c'est assez peu c'est aussi
beaucoup
[Musique]
recherche en fait a plutôt la réputation
d'être obéissance elle aime mais ce
projet de guerre ne fait pas l'unanimité
et notamment parce que il en fera un
certain nombre de normes de
représentation
en tout cas ce rebelle contre le pouvoir
exécutif c'est-à-dire qu'il joue la loi
contre le pouvoir exécutif politique
va convaincre aussi une large partie de
l'opinion c'est vrai que tout le projet
de Poutine il date de très longtemps
depuis 10 ans il prépare la société
russe pour convaincre tant que l'OTAN
que l'Occident et l'ennemi et c'est
aussi pour ça que beaucoup de militaires
sont très prudents dans l'expression
publique à l'OTAN où les Européens pour
ne pas donner
lieu à être utilisé instrumentalisé par
les médias ensuite pour dire vous voyez
bien bon les Russes sont victimes de la
haine occidentale qui va être
instrumentalisée c'est la visite de Joe
Biden aujourd'hui elle s'inscrit
parfaitement dans le dans la rhétorique
de Poutine d'une guerre défensive que
lui livre l'OTAN n'est-ce pas il y a pas
moyen d'y échapper complètement le
président américain complètement et
d'ailleurs on le voit bien dans le
narratif russe depuis depuis le début
c'est effectivement c'est la Russie qui
est agressée et elle a dû intervenir
pour venir parce qu'il y avait un
génocide enfin bon
par les russophone du Dombas etc
aussi comme argumentation
Véronique un mot juste sur l'économie
votre Le Figaro économique demain
un ensemble complet sur comment
justement l'économie russe finalement a
pas mal résisté à une première année de
sanction oui alors il faut savoir que la
Russie c'est un des pays qui est le
moins entré dans la mondialisation il a
une économie de pays finalement on voit
de développement qui est basé
essentiellement sur le commerce des
matières premières et donc les sanctions
latteignent beaucoup moins qu'on aurait
pu le croire
distrus industrialisés que nous pardon
n'est-ce pas donc ils ont encore une
sizérurgie
beaucoup d'US
jackpot qui tire de la vente de l'ordre
du pétrole de leur matière voilà c'est
un agriculture performante et remise à
niveau après 2014 c'est quelque chose
que l'on oublie c'est que évidemment les
sanctions des sanctions
performante donc il y a pas de risque de
pénurie alimentaire il peut y avoir des
pénuries sur certains produits de luxe
mais maintenant il y a des moyens de
contourner par la Géorgie donc
finalement ça touche assez peu la
population et puis il faut savoir que il
y a une grande partie du monde qui
continue à commercer avec la Russie qui
n'est pas alignée sur la posture de
l'Occident
et qui est beaucoup plus marqué que que
dans les précédents conflits on en
arrive à ce second point sur le rôle des
armoires via la Russie est-ce que
l'appareil industrie militaro industriel
russe est capable de
régénérer et de tenir
la distance face à l'aide occidentale
généraliste en fait c'est assez
compliqué parce que sur les matériels
haut de gamme ils sont confrontés à une
vraie difficulté d'abord il était
confronté à la difficulté de la mise au
point de des derniers équipements par
exemple le Sukoi 57 dans l'aviation dans
l'aviation qui est un quand on voit
c'est un bel appareil mais de ce qui
compte c'est ce qui est à l'intérieur là
ils ont des difficultés le char T14
armata qui a été présenté pour la
première fois en 2015 ils arrivent pas à
aller jusqu'au bout la seule chose c'est
que ils ont d'abord des stocks colossaux
et on se rend compte d'ailleurs que ils
ont tout conservé
par exemple des missiles de l'époque
soviétique des missiles airsol à
kérosène dire mettre en oeuvre c'est
prendre un risque enfin il y a plus un
missile de ce type là dans les pays
occidentaux parce qu'on risque de perdre
exactement bon et on voit ils ont sorti
des chars t64 64 c'est l'année de sortie
de chars donc ils ont des stocks quasi
on va dire quasiment illimité mais
effectivement ils ont quand même réussi
à passer en économie de guerre dans
certains secteurs donc au lieu de
produire du T4 du T14 armata bah il
rénove du du T72 et du T90 donc ils ont
quand même des capacités et puis il y a
aussi quand même un système D c'est pas
hyper performant et il bénéficie il faut
pas l'oublier bon des drones iraniens la
question se pose sur les relations avec
la Chine donc il faut être très prudent
sur
sur l'attrition du système militaire ou
industriel russe vous avez vécu en
Russie donc vous vous pensez vous que
cette économie là ce pays là avec son
savoir-faire ses vieilles industries etc
et quand même capable de remettre sur
pied une armée
alors
je partage complètement votre point de
vue c'est que sur les armements
ultra performants qui seraient conforme
à ce que à une guerre très moderne une
guerre contemporaine un engagement
contre le temps non ils auraient
nécessairement le sous mais en ce qui
concerne la guerre d'artillerie qui se
passe à l'heure actuelle dans le bon
basse et dans toute l'Ukraine peut-être
prochainement sur plusieurs fronts pour
le moment dans le long de base au
contraire je pense que le l'état des
forces qui sont plutôt adaptées à ce
genre de guerre et c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on voit qu'il n'engage que très peu
d'avions dans l'espace aérien ukrainien
c'est ce qu'ils essayent de limiter les
pertes de leurs avions parce qu'ils n'en
n'ont pas beaucoup que ces appareils
coûts extrêmement chers et puis ce qu'on
voit c'est qu'il y a une demande en fait
de monter en puissance de production
militaire qui a été envoyée par
l'appareil politique à toutes les
industries du secteur ce qu'on appelait
complexe militarro industriel qui n'a
jamais été véritablement réformée parce
que ça aurait nécessité de licencier
vraiment énormément de militaires et de
créer un mécontentement très important
dans la population et en plus de ça
l'augmente l'augmentation du niveau de
vigilance dans les territoires
limitrophes de l'Ukraine permettent dans
ces régions là de mettre une partie des
actifs économiques privés au service de
la production pour la défense donc il y
a vraiment beaucoup d'éléments qui sont
réunis pour que la Russie puisse durer
si la guerre ne change pas de nature sur
le terrain mais en tout cas tenir la vie
est-ce que les Occidentaux ont une
vision à peu près claire de ce que la
Russie est capable de faire
ce qu'on est dans le brouillard en fait
non dans le brouillard il y a des
indications
on voit bien les liens avec l'Iran qui
fournit des drones c'est un élément
important la Corée du Nord et des
spéculations sur ce que la Chine
pourrait faire ou pas de la mise en
garde contre aujourd'hui mais de boîte
noire là sur la Russie on ne sait pas
combien de temps le système peut tenir
ce qui peut produire et c'est pas qu'il
y a urgence côté occidental a aussi
mettre en Brant l'économie de guerre la
production pour fournir des munitions
mettant des munitions aux écrire pour
qu'ils puissent se battre sur sur le
front on va y revenir dans une seconde
juste sur l'aspect des missiles ils
continuent les russes continuent à tirer
des missiles on nous a expliqué depuis
un certain temps il n'avait plus de
microprocesseurs
pour faire des missiles intelligents
quand l'hémicides tombent ou sont
détruits par les Ukrainiens on doit
pouvoir analyser le la qualité des
missiles qui ont été tirés par les
Russes des composants
occidentaux dans ces dans ces missiles
après bien se rendre compte qu'il y a
plusieurs types de salves il y a les
drones qui vont servir faire déclencher
la défense entière il y a donc épuisé
les ressources ukrainiennes on va avoir
des tirs de missiles solaires peu précis
qui font du dégâts très bien et après le
peu de missiles de précision que les
Russes vont utiliser ils les mettent
dans ces salles-là pour toucher un
objectif parmi d'autres on sait que la
proportions des missiles antiques et des
missiles modernes dans les salles en
fait ça dépend en gros il tire entre
entre 50 et 80
missiles drones là dedans on va dire que
il y en a un quart de moderne et puis le
reste c'est ça me permet de faire du
bruit et comme le disait très bien
Nicolas Barotte bah ça oblige les
Ukrainiens à disperser leur effort dans
la défense solaire alors Véronique
guillerma les Russes sont clairement
passé en économie de guerre est-ce que
les Occidentaux sont capables de passer
à leur tour ou doivent d'ailleurs passer
à leur tour en économie de guerre alors
les communiquent ça voudrait dire que
toutes nos ind même celles qui ne sont
pas militaires se mettent au service des
armées c'est pas le temps utile voilà
quand elles sont utiles c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui en revanche on sent chez les
industriels que on est au-delà de la
prise de conscience qu'il y a des actes
maintenant qui sont qui sont menés pour
augmenter les cadences de production à
la demande du politique on se rappelle
manuel Macron dès l'été qui appelait
toute l'industrie européenne a passé
justement en mode économie de guerre
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
produire plus c'est plus vite justement
on va écouter ce qu'a dit Emmanuel
Macron sur ce sujet il l'a dit il y a
deux jours à Munich
nous sommes prêts à intensifier
aujourd'hui car les semaines et les mois
qui viennent sont décisifs et nous
sommes prêts à un conflit prolongé en
disant cela je ne le souhaite pas
mais surtout s'il ne le souhaitons pas
nous devons collectivement être crédible
dans notre capacité à durée dans cet
effort et c'est ainsi que la France
s'inscrit dans celui-ci alors comment ça
se traduit en France déjà un groupe très
connu qui fabrique le canon César qui
sait illustré que les
Ukrainiens utilisent très régulièrement
donc le groupe Nexter a triplé sa
capacité de production début d'année
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui il est
capable par mois de sortir si talons et
c'était deux par mois l'année dernière
ça c'est un premier exemple concret
vous avez on a eu l'occasion avec
Nicolas
site de radar en Europe à Limours en
Essonne si je fais pas d'erreur est
opéré par le groupe Thalès et là il se
mette dans la position de doubler leur
capacité de production de radar avant
même d'avoir signé des ok on est en
train d'assister à un changement de
logiciel chez les industriels de
l'armement qui vont prendre plus de
risques en engageant sur leur capitaux
propres le financement de mon terme
cadence recruter des personnels parce
que c'est aussi un problème de
ressources humaines tout simplement pour
venir dans les usines fabriquer des
armements et qui donc vont produire plus
et plus vite
j'ai un autre exemple en tête assez
récent le directeur général du groupe
Safran qui est à la fois un producteur
de moteur d'avion de ligne mais aussi un
producteur de bombe pour les militaires
qui vient de sortir le patroleur qui est
le nouveau drone tactique de l'armée de
terre le directeur général a déclaré moi
en m'inspirant des méthodes et des
process de monter en cadence rapide dans
l'industrie civile je peux développer à
très grande vitesse une version armée du
patron leur c'est à dire deux
la difficulté c'est que il faut
simultanément
fournir des moyens aux forces
ukrainiennes donc des moyens soit on a
en stock quoi que l'on assure étagère et
simultanément en même temps augmenter
pour nos propres besoins parce que c'est
ça aussi l'un des enjeux c'est à dire
que on était complètement sous-équipé
nos forces étaient construits sur un
modèle qui était celui notamment des
opérations extérieures
au Sahel et là on se rend compte qu'il
faut beaucoup plus beaucoup plus je vais
vous donner un chiffre
en 2022 le coût du déploiement trancher
à l'est de l'Europe d'ailleurs en
Roumanie et dans les États baltes donc
pour assurer pour garantir la sécurité
parce que c'est concret cette fameuse
réassurance 666 millions d'euros en 2022
c'est pas négligeable quand vous avez un
escadron de Charles Leclerc qui est en
Roumanie
ça coûte cher mais c'est aussi une
garantie pour les Roumains voir aussi
pour les moldavres parce qu'ils savent
que derrière oui il y a quelque chose de
concret maintenant la difficulté c'est
que
fabriquer un tube de canon ça c'est pas
une appli sur smartphone qu'on peut
développer en quelques heures voire
quelques jours il faut des il faut des
aciers il faut des produits et par
exemple concernant les poudres les
poudres c'est un c'est un cauchemar
pourquoi parce que vous avez en plus la
réglementation européenne reach qui fait
que aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
poudre qu'on peut plus fabriquer en
Europe donc là aussi il y a parce que
c'est pas écologique il y a tout un
travail alors la Commission européenne
commence à comprendre les enjeux mais
effectivement
il faut passer de l’herbivore à
carnivore donc il y a des
réglementations qu'il faut faire évoluer
mais dans l'urgence c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on peut on peut pas attendre
trois ou quatre ans il faut aller très
vite parce que pendant ce temps-là et
bien le temps tourne et les Ukrainiens
ils ont besoin d'obus à tel point que
pour les poudres si je peux me permettre
l'accord avec l'Australie on va
travailler avec des poudres magnétos
australiens
quand on les chiffres dont on a parlé en
double une production mais c'était deux
canons par mois ont passé 6 ans triple
c'est pas un peu dérisoire ces chiffres
là qu'on parait à ce que peut faire un
pays comme la Russie
même si ces deux qualités inférieure
dans le cas des pays qui comme nous
plafonnés difficiles au-delà de 2% de
PIB d'évoluent à la défense oui ça peut
paraître dérisoire mais le fait est que
nous ne sommes pas seuls cet engagement
n'absence que de manière collective et
c'est ça qui est intéressant finalement
à mon sens politiquement cette année au
combien dérangeantes et douloureuse est
aussi un accélérateur incroyable
d'intégration européenne
particulièrement dans un domaine où on
pensait avoir perdu tout espoir qui
était quand même la défense l'industrie
et la politique de défense et peut-être
que à la faveur de cette épreuve nous
sommes en train de découvrir l'ampleur
des besoins et notre capacité à
travailler ensemble déjà ce qui n'était
pas sûr et peut-être à ne pas pouvoir
survivre dans le monde international
autrement que par cette alliance donc ce
n'est peut-être pas si mal un décollage
multiplication des différents matériels
parce que pour les Ukrainiens très
compliqué à gérer logistiquement d'avoir
ce qu'on s'est engagé dans cette voie
d'harmonisation de d'essayer de
fabriquer des oui non c'est qu'on a
quand même des matériels qui sont
existants qu'on en voit et si on envoie
en Ukraine des challengers des MX10 des
léopards ça fait plusieurs types de
chars même chose pour avertirie donc la
logistique est aussi un vrai enjeu pour
sur le terrain et alors l'Union
européenne est en train d'examiner la
possibilité d'appliquer aux munitions le
même système que au vaccin aux achats de
vaccins ça c'est c'est prometteur aussi
ça peut accélérer effectivement la
commande en grande quantité
de production justement où est-ce qu'on
va les trouver c'est tous ces obus qu'il
faut acheter justement les industriels
ont bien compris ce qui se passait donc
ils commencent à constituer des stocks
de précaution pour anticiper les
commandes qui arrivent donc des stocks
de ce qu'on peut en stratégique des
stocks de tout simplement assez spéciaux
de titane quand on a besoin pour
fabriquer les armements de César ça tire
quoi mille coups c'est ça et après il
faut changer faites où il y a une usure
mais s'il est entretenu
il doit tirer beaucoup plus longtemps la
problématique c'est que les canons César
les 18 qui ont été livrés ont été
extrêmement sollicités donc il y a tout
un travail de on appelle de maintien en
conditions opérationnelles donc il y a
des flux logistiques et là il faut il
faut souligner que les Ukrainiens ont
bien compris que ça servait à rien de
multiplier
les parcs c'est la raison pour lequel si
on concernant bambelais la demande de
Charles Leclerc c'est absolument pas une
priorité pour les Ukrainiens parce que
ils savent que c'est parce qu'on veut
bien leur donner mais la priorité c'est
autour du léopard parce que il y a à peu
près 1500 Charles léopard plus ou moins
disponible en Europe donc il y a il y a
cette réalité maintenant il y a quelque
chose aussi qui est extrêmement
important c'est que on pourrait dire oui
mais après tout bon fournit et admettons
que dans six mois la guerre soit
terminée parce que les Russes se
replient et que après tout ça ça
vraiment une fois qu'on a fini la guerre
on replie
on reprend les Césars sauf que là on est
rentré dans une confrontation c'est une
nouvelle vraiment le scénario et puis de
toute façon quoi qu'il arrive en fait
c'est une nouvelle guerre froide qui est
engagée c'est à dire que il y a une
rupture définitive entre la Russie et on
va dire je vais pas dire le reste du
monde mais le monde occidental c'est un
vrai rideau de fer donc de toute façon
la vigilance armée elle va s'imposer
dire on va revenir là-dessus sur le
dernier point parce que c'est lié à la
notion de défaite russe de victoire
ukrainienne etc mais avant d'en arriver
à ce point Nicolas Barotte est-ce que on
met pas les la charrue avant les bœufs
en ce en
en essayant de produire des ou de livrer
d'ailleurs des armements sans réfléchir
à l'effet recherché on m'a expliqué que
dans les états majeurs ont résonné en
termes d'effets et on adapté les moyens
à les faire rechercher or en entend
toujours les Ukrainiens nous demandaient
des moyens sans nous expliquer
exactement quels effets sont recherchés
du conflit donc on soutient les
Ukrainiens mais on les laisse faire leur
guerre jusqu'à un certain point prenons
l'exemple concret des chars dont on a
beaucoup parlé quel est l'effet
recherché avec
la mise en place de bataillon de chars
sur le terrain pour ça à quoi ça peut
servir il faut revenir effectivement à
l'automne au moment où les Russes se
retirent de Carson et donc l'offensive
ukrainienne à un moment donné les
Ukrainiens n'avaient pas assez de
ressources pour avancer avoir un
avantage en profiter et percer les
lignes pourquoi ce qui manquait aussi de
de moyens blindés pour aller vite tout
bêtement le chat il permet de progresser
sur les lignes et de déstabiliser
l'adversaire l'utilité principale du
char cette percer les lignes de défense
qui n'a pas réussi en gros les
Ukrainiens ont perdu 450 chars de combat
qui était tous d'ailleurs le modèle
soviétique ça c'est facile bon ils en
ont récupéré les Russes en ont perdu
1500 1500 et donc en fait on est dans
des alors c'est vrai que on a à la fois
assez intéressant à observer on a à la
fois la Première Guerre mondiale avec la
guerre de tranchée l'artillerie on a la
deuxième guerre mondiale avec la
puissance de feu les chars mais il faut
rajouter là-dessus la guerre du 21e
siècle avec le numérique
voilà les drones mais là il faut
reconnaître qu'à un moment donné c'est
la notion de rapport de force c'est à
dire combien de combattants combien de
pièces d'artillerie et le chat il est
indispensable pour percer surtout que
c'est aussi le paradoxe de l'histoire ce
sont des terrains qui sont favorables à
la manœuvre en char c'est la grande
plaine de l'Europe donc si vous n'avez
pas de chat et que vous allez à pied
vous êtes mort donc il faut une masse
blindée avec des chars de reconnaissance
c'est les mix du RC qui va être alors
c'est aussi la paradoxe de l'histoire
c'est que la mx-10rc donc nous sommes en
train de livrer aux Ukrainiens a été
conçu dans les années 70 pour effectuer
des missions de reconnaissance offensive
ou défensifs passent au Pacte de
Varsovie il va être employé exactement
pour la mission laquelle il avait été
bougé que tous les chars lourds en
Europe de l'Ouest était aussi oui avec
tout cet été conçu en fait pour faire
face d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs Poutine
joue là-dessus c'est à dire que le
léopard il a été conçu pour casser du
T72 mais c'est ce qui va jusqu'à présent
il y a jamais eu de confrontation dans
dans les conflits périphériques on peut
dire la guerre Iran Irak ou
semaine là on va au Koweït les chats
Abraham sont descendus en District 72
mais bon voilà c'était déjà il y a
longtemps là on va avoir du alors je
caricature mais du Panzer allemand parce
que c'est le terme qui va être utilisé
par par les Russes à la propagande par
la propagande contre le reprenez oui
voilà pour illustrer
mais pour illustrer c'est ce qui va se
passer et donc il faut que vous ayez la
masse blindée et dans des sur des des
espaces de manœuvre qui pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et c'est ça
aussi l'une des problématiques ont connu
les plus grandes batailles de chars
notamment à Koursk course que c'est dans
la région donc
retour de l'histoire c'est ça aussi ce
qui est assez intéressant ici au début
pour compenser la masse qui manque de
crayon c'est que les chars-anto ont une
tenté de tir qui est plus longue et donc
en fait ils pourront tirer les premiers
sur les positions russes donc là même si
on est moins nombreux on a un avantage
qui est évident
sur le terrain
Elsa on a il y a un élément intéressant
qui est on a publié hier un sondage de
l'Ifop qui montre que dans cette pays
européens
l'image d'Ukraine reste bien supérieure
et meilleur à l'image de la Russie mais
le soutien notamment à la fourniture
d'armes n'est pas universel c'est 70% en
Pologne et c'est seulement 49% en
Allemagne 54% en France alors la
bataille de l'opinion
est-ce que elle peut être perdue côté
occidental perdu je n'en suis pas du
tout persuadée je pense que l'opinion a
tenu bien mieux qu'une partie des
cercles dirigeants bien mieux notamment
à la hausse du prix des matières
premières et l'électricité on disait cet
hiver
relativement doux mais ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'il y a quand même une
sensibilité et une identification à la
situation
ukrainienne une identification aussi à
[Musique]
un impact de cette guerre pour l'Europe
mais qu'effectivement les gens sont
beaucoup plus ambivalents vis-à-vis du
régime de sanctions contre la Russie et
des armes des livraisons d'arbres et ça
se décline vraiment en fonction de la
proximité géographique et de l'histoire
de ces pays-là et gérer
nettement moins concerné puisqu'on est
quand même avec une grosse façade
atlantique et il y a plein d'autres
États qui font tampon entre nous et la
Russie et puis on a aussi une
spécificité tous les États en ont une
mais en France il y a quand même un une
indulgence que je trouve coupable à
force de répétition une indulgence
vis-à-vis du recours à la force par la
Russie de Vladimir Poutine qu'on a
tendance trop facilement à assimiler à
le rétablissement d'un ordre juste la
Russie ayant ayant été humilié par
l'Occident bon alors que l'Union
soviétique c'est dissoute toute seule
bon là on abonde très facilement dans
des termes de langage qui sont se repris
par les politologues russes
à la force et puis qui qui viennent
aussi rappeler que nous sommes avant
tout des alliés dans l'histoire avec la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et puis au
niveau mondial contre l'hégémonie
américaine homme semble que dans la
priorisation des menaces immédiates pour
la sécurité en Europe et pour la France
il y a quand même un ménage à faire et
peut-être replacer les choses dans une
autre perspective et voilà la France est
assez indulgente vis-à-vis de la Russie
c'est très vrai dans certains sacs
militaires du renseignement et de la
diplomatie et puis ça a été très
habilement entretenu aussi par les
techniciens de des sondages et des
réseaux sociaux russes des femmes atrols
qui savent très bien faire fond aussi
sur toutes les dissensions de toutes les
sociétés
il semble ces derniers temps que les
dirigeants européens et atteint un
niveau de clarté stratégique un peu plus
nette que qu'auparavant c'est notamment
le cas d'Emmanuel Macron qu'on a entendu
tout à l'heure on n'hésite déjà parlé de
défaite il faut que tu sois une défaite
pour la Russie il faut que ce soit une
victoire pour l'Ukraine on sait pas
exactement le contenu concret qu'on met
dans ces notions là mais déjà sur le
simple fait de d'être passé à ce type de
discours général pénis Randy comment
vous l'analysez en fait depuis le 24
février le conflit il est existentiel
pour l'Ukraine très clairement si
l'Ukraine voilà donc le présente comme
l'existentielle pour la Russie très
souvent mais ça c'est quelque chose qui
est on va dire c'est cet automne cet
automne le conflit dans l'enlèvement
devient existentiel pour la Russie et
pour le régime de Poutine mais
maintenant je crois que c'est nouveau
c'est qu'il est devenu existentiel pour
l'Europe c'est à dire que si l'Europe du
bomba près tout les Ukrainiens vous a
bien aidés bon maintenant vous retrouver
une négociation un truc comme ça bah moi
je suis désolé c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé en 1938 à Munich parce que
il faut être clair il y a un moment et
je crois que les dirigeants européens
alors d'abord il est vrai aussi pour
rejoindre ce que disent les Avidan c'est
que il y a à la fois une russophilie
très coupable chez nous et en même temps
une méconnée on a complètement on a plus
cette connaissance que l'on avait à
l'époque quand il y avait les
soviétologues qui qui était capable de
dire tiens Malène coffre journal des
crèmes Limoges et donc on a totalement
parce que il y a eu aussi le doux
commerce bon il y a la relation entre
l'Allemagne et la Russie qu'il faut
éclaircir et donc on a complètement
abandonné ou en tout cas les vrais
experts sur les questions russes on
était devenu beaucoup moins sexy
on se rend compte et parce que il y a
aussi quelque chose qu'il faut bien
prendre en compte c'est que
effectivement cette existentiel pour
l'Europe pourquoi parce que il y a aussi
le fait que le régime russe devl
Vladimir Poutine est devenu totalitaire
c'est-à-dire que il y a une remise la
cause totalement de ce qui constitue
alors plus ou moins les valeurs les
valeurs européennes donc
cette existentielle pour quand on dit
que cette existentiel est-ce que vous
croyez que le citoyen français le
perçoit comme existentiel il faut enfin
il faudrait justement lui expliquer que
notre sécurité elle se joue là-bas oui
le fait que la Russie soit une dictature
et même le fait que la Russie envahisse
un voisin est-ce que ça suffit même
lorsque les Ukrainiens disent si nous
nous échouons il y aura d'autres
victimes les moldavres peut-être la
Pologne peut-être les Baltes est-ce que
même ce discours là suffit à impliquer
les citoyens français assez un problème
de politique
la montée des populismes en Europe
sondage qu'on a publié les pays où le
soutien est le plus faible il y a la
France mais Marine Le Pen au second tour
il y a l'Allemagne mais de la FD depuis
8 ans à émergé d'une preuve politique
qui sout la Russie plus ou moins
l'Italie même chose dans la Mélanie ton
plutôt pouvoir
de l'hégémonie américaine et un peu
mécaniquement par
glissement sur la multipolarité et on
peut tolérer effectivement l'usage de la
force par par la Russie
Emmanuel Macron qu'on a entendu tout à
l'heure dit nous nous sommes prêts pour
une guerre longue il parle que il parle
pour lui ou il parle selon vous pour
le pays
qui est en train de s'organiser bon
simplement l'industrie de l'armement je
dirais si on était vraiment en guerre on
s'organiserait de manière un petit peu
plus énergique non il faudrait en
général il faudrait c'est quand même une
guerre à distance oui c'est une guerre
c'est une guerre indistance mais il y a
aussi et mais je crois oui ici que ce
qui a joué d'ailleurs sur le changement
du discours du de la République c'est
aussi le fait il y a notamment l'Afrique
et le fait que la Russie à travers
Wagner et on a vu Sergueï lavrof le
ministre des Affaires étrangères
accueilli à Bamako le télé au Soudan il
y a une vraie volonté de déstabilisation
de la part de la Russie de entre
guillemets nous chasser de voilà et ça
c'est quelque chose peut-être que l'on
n'avait pas tout à fait pris pris en
compte donc on est à un moment une
rupture géopolitique
on a connu le 11 septembre mais
honnêtement le 24 février c'est pire que
le 11 septembre le 11 septembre a pris
pour 20 ans mais là on a une rupture qui
est beaucoup plus grave beaucoup plus
profonde plus longtemps
cette semaine au large de l'Afrique du
Sud il y a un exercice militaire qui
valait les Russes les Chinois et les
Sud-Africains c'est bien le symbole que
cet ordre géopolitique a changé avec des
puissances qui s'organisent et qui
indifférente on va leur que l'Occident
veut promouvoir
l'Afrique en construisant des aéroports
des routes enfin on retrouve nos deux
meilleurs ennemis qui sont là où ils
sont un peu en compétition en Afrique
ils peuvent aussi se
faire un terrain de leur amitié sans
limite on a un peu encerclé si on trace
une ligne comme ça
à ce point quand même de de défaite
Emmanuel Macron dit ce week-end que il
veut la défaite de la Russie mais sans
l'écraser qu'est-ce que ça veut dire on
peut parce que c'est pas hors sujet non
c'est pas hors sujet et en fait je pense
que
la durabilité la solidité de notre
alliance nous les occidentaux dépend de
cela d'un débat qu'on est obligé de
repousser de la sphère publique le plus
longtemps possible pour garder l'unité à
l'intérieur de l'Ukraine et dans le
front des alliés mais en fait il y a
deux issues possibles quand on dit la
défaite de la Russie c'est armistice ou
traité de paix c'est le feu c'est soit
une défaite la Russie est défaite sur le
champ de bataille elle est dans la
récupère tous leurs territoires y
compris
ils mènent une bataille qui est si
décisive que les capacités militaires
russes sont durablement
détruites désorientés des organisées et
que le coût politique devient intenable
par exemple vis-à-vis de l'opinion
intérieure ou voilà une catastrophe sur
l'ensemble des du champ de bataille pour
les Russes et auquel cas on peut se
finir gentiment si ça se passe comme ça
non probablement pas et surtout là on
retombe dans des projections on retombe
dans la crainte de l'escalade du conflit
l'acclin la crainte de la confrontation
autant Russie l'escalade nucléaire
la réactivation de ce type de rhétorique
donc il y a quand même aussi en ce
moment des réflexions qui se font en
disant que peut-être on aurait intérêt à
maintenir une pression militaire
supérieure à celle qui est à l'oeuvre à
l'heure actuelle de manière à infliger
défaites peut-être pas si décisive mais
en tout cas incapacitante répétée
coûteuse économiquement coûteuse en
homme coûteuse politiquement tout en
continuant notre arsenal pour que
effectivement elle entendent qu'il est
qu'il soit possible d'être plus opportun
pour elle de venir négocier voilà
d'accord la Russie et le sens pas le
même tempo en fait de la guerre c'est
que le dire petites et sur un temps très
long son objectif c'est affaiblir
l'Occident l'Europe et il se donne des
années pour le faire on a bien vu tout à
l'heure que pour l'Occident il y a ce
problème d'opinion publique il y a le
problème des ukrainien qui sont moins
nombreux et donc le temps de la guerre
pour gagner et beaucoup plus court et
c'est vrai que pour les Ukrainiens c'est
de c'est de laisser Poutine installer un
conflit gelé 15 ans on y pensera plus ça
sera entré dans la dans l'ordinaire de
notre risque apprécié par les Américains
on dit beaucoup que l'administration
Biden évata en guerre etc je crois pas
du tout qu'il soit la tanga au contraire
ils auraient plutôt une préférence pour
une issue un peu plus rapide moins
coûteuse moins coûteuse aussi en termes
de vote bientôt il y aura une élection
présidentielle aux États-Unis il n'y a
pas du tout d’unanimisme dans la société
américaine quant à l'aide à apporter aux
Ukrainiens donc une sortie de cette
guerre assez rapide un an un an et demi
donc parce qu'en fait
le lit d'une négociation plus globale
sur l'Ukraine avec un point qui est très
intéressant de service c'est que à aucun
moment que ce soit Washington à Paris ou
à Londres on demande un changement de
régime en Russie voilà en même temps on
peut en parler parce que derrière la
notion de victoire ou de défaite russe
il y a quand même la notion que le
régime pourrait en être déstabilisé mais
l'histoire aussi d'abord en Russie mais
je parle sur le contrôle d'Elsa il y a
jamais eu de révolution par le peuple
les Révolution ont toujours été par le
avec vrai partout donc avec des déf oui
mais avec des défaites militaires
c'est-à-dire en 1905 c'est-à-dire le
tsar est obligé de larguer du lest 1917
février puis octobre bon donc c'est ça
la difficulté dire qu'en fait
effectivement il faudrait que à un
moment donné bon les militaires russes
disent bon le coup à payer quand même on
négocie c'est le feu on se replie alors
après sur quel frontière est-ce que
c'est celle du 24 février est-ce que
c'est celle
de 91 il y a donc Kissinger qui suggère
alors Kissinger c'est effectivement le
grand maître à penser il est dans sa
centième année et en quelque sorte par
exemple et ben on dit aux Ukrainiens ok
on fait vous faites abstraction de la
Crimée mais vous rentrez dans l'OTAN
donc mais pour le moment toutes ces
discussions elles sont prématurées
c'est-à-dire que ça peut être des plans
pour le moment c'est c'est la guerre
elle pose un risque en plus d'être
prématuré elle pose un risque très très
important c'est que si elles étaient
menées dans l'espace public comme
clientèle en reconnaissant que peut-être
contre une entrée dans le temps les
Ukrainiens pourraient renoncer à la
Crimée on est à peu près sûr que zellens
qui perdrait son soutien unanime Hank en
Ukraine et qu'on pourrait se retrouver
avec des avec des compétiteurs avec
plusieurs interlocuteurs Ukrainiens or
cela on veut absolument l'éviter sinon
ce serait la défaite absolue donc il
faut repousser cette discussion au plus
tard ou peut-être hors de la reine
publique le plus longtemps possible
Nicolas Barotte on arrive près de la fin
de cette émission est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que
Emmanuel Macron et sincère lorsque il
souhaite vraiment la victoire de
l'Ukraine est-ce qu'il y croit parce que
certains commentateurs doutent qui y
croient en fait
oui je pense qu'il y croit il a essayé
de négocier c'était possible avec
Vladimir Poutine il constate à l'Elysée
que ça ne fonctionne pas il y a cette
pression uneanime des Européens pour
avancer notamment des pays de l'Est qui
est pas du tout sur une île de
négociation mais plutôt pour soutenir du
crâne au maximum pour pouvoir négocier
pour pouvoir avoir une paix dans les
meilleures conditions pour les
Ukrainiens donc Macron est réaliste
après ce qu'il veut éviter c'est que
c'est une équations échappent aux
Européens il va avoir son mot à dire et
donc il faut bien qu'à un moment donné
on se reconnaît comme un interlocuteur
je pense est très difficile parce que
Poutine considère que les Européens sont
ces adversaires bon je pense pas qu'il
aille demander à amener le Macron
ensuite son aide pour négocier
c'est que du côté de les pays réels de
l'économie des chefs d'entreprise on est
parti pour le long terme
je pense qu'il y a une prise de
conscience qu'il faut aller plus vite et
ça va être soutenu par la prochaine loi
de programmation des décennies à venir
quelque chose qui va se finir d'ici au
printemps prochain le sentiment qu'on a
en parlant avec les industriels c'est
qu'ils sont dans un temps long et que ça
va être soutenu par la loi de
programmation militaire va quand même
acter une hausse importante des budgets
de défense déjà en France et c'est le
cas c'est général dans toute l'Europe
donc là on rentre dans une autre période
de l'histoire de l'armement avec des
hausse de cadence beaucoup plus de
production plus d'équipements
glacial avec des risques extrêmement
graves donc il faut rester extrêmement
prudent
le mot de la fin
la désintégration en fait l'extraction
de la Russie du système monde c'est ce
qui nous est arrivé en cette année en
fait on a vu la fin et l'explosion en
vol de 30 ans d'intégration de la Russie
dans le système européen dans le système
monde et de nombreux efforts dont nous
avons été les témoins ont volé en éclat
et la guerre
ce matin je disais justement que les
Occidentaux n'avaient pas fait assez
pour essayer d'intégrer la réussite
peut-être pas totalement tort merci à
tous
[Musique]